(static)
- You know I probably
shouldn't use alcohol
to drown the pain but
Homegirl loved Century Club.
Hundred shots 100 minutes.
I'm in, let's do this.
Let's do this.
(clearing throat)
It's an American thing.
- Umm, if I could
have your attention,
I just wanted to let
you know Blake and I
have channeled our sadness
regarding Homegirl's passing
into a charity in
Homegirl's name.
- Homegirl's Home for
Girls Without Homes.
- Well, I've also
made an organization
that's gonna raise money
to cure brain tumorism.
It's called Rollerblading
Across the Americas.
- Oh yeah, north and south?
- And east and west if
it'll find a goddamned cure.
- Okay, well, all the
money in the world
isn't gonna do anything
to bring Homegirl back.
The only way to
keep Homegirl alive
is to name stuff after
her like charities
or skateboard tricks.
Blake?
- Uh.
- Show 'em the Homegirl.
(cluncking)
(footsteps)
(claps)
- Homegirl.
- Woah.
- You didn't show
her much respect
by not using her real name.
- Yeah, well, obviously
it's that then.
- It's what then?
- It's her name if that works.
- And what's her name Ders?
She had a name dude.
And her name
was Roberta Paulson.
Her name was Roberta Paulson.
- [Group] Her name
was Roberta Paulson.
- Guys.
- [Group] Her name
is Roberta Paulson.
- How do you say
seance in Swedish?
- (speaking in foreign language)
- Then let us have a
(mumbling)
- Alice, you gotta
shut it down now.
- What?
- Homegirl's wake, shut
it down now, please.
- Nobody's butthurt,
not anymore.
We're all, we're all butthealed.
- Yeah, our butts are the
picture of perfect health.
- Praise the butt god.
- The wake has to keep going.
Her kids are on their way over
with some kind of video will.
- Woah, whose video will is it?
Like a cool little droid dude?
- No, it's like a video
with last words or wishes.
- Wait, no, but
Adam's up there going
out of control on
the mic device.
He was singing a song, and
like, I don't know what he's
gonna do next.
- Ders.
No, video will,
that's a great idea.
I don't know, it would've
been cool if it was a robot.
Video will, video
will, what's up.
- Mr. Nate Dogg, are you there?
I just have but one question
for you Mr. Nate Dogg.
How do I make it into heaven?
(loudly groaning)
(haunting electronic music)
Ay-yay.
Smoke weed every day.
(haunting electronic music)
Luckily I do so I guess
I'm goin' to heaven.